I'm excited I love surprising people do
you yes I eat surprising people the old
people that there's a new universal
Comedy Tour that's the first people to
do and we're supposed to go talk to
these people they're gonna play cornhole
against um what if they are not excited
you guys excited yeah I have a trailer
here it's a trailer from neighbors -
it's coming out May 20th we're neighbors
they're watching our trailer I'm
switching sides about my dad bought how
long ago do you guys think he works out
or that just comes naturally just I'm
very nice it comes natural or not it
over here but I have a little surprise
for you okay take a look at that house
did you recognize it from the trailer
that you just saw no I am nervous I'm
nervous
it's from neighbors too this is where
they film that you guys he's staying in
we're gonna be so funny if some people
stay ready yeah oh my god look she knows
the move you guys are just tourists are
they I am strictly oh my gosh this looks
so cute you guys alright on the count of
three I'm really nervous
so really really silly one all right
ready you guys get in there silly and
crazy ready 1 2 3
yeah now we're gonna play cornhole
against each other right now all about
dams that Zac Efron that was amazing oh
the other one is really funny and see
like competitive side get some bark on
it have any cash on Zachary come on Zach
oh please surprise and Zac Efron's bump
wait I think you guys are stretching
that was maybe the worst one for Chloe
and Rosie throw one and whoever gets it
closer with for all the beanbags
thank you for corn hauling with us we
hope you enjoyed it and please go see
neighbors to may 20th in theaters check
it out he's amazing poor noise no it's
one point when it stays on and then if
you make it in at three okay that's how
the real game quit Zacks a cornhole
purist